Peace be upon you. This is Omar Mohsen, completing his
course in Excel and Word, which are in the
video description. I decided to make a simple,
delicious little video for you about Word shortcuts.
Follow me. The first shortcut is the link or
hyperlink. If I want to make a link on an
existing text, I have a shadow on it. Control it so that I can
continue to do it.  Control, so that this box appears for me, I will
write the name of the website in it and do OK, and that is how I
made a hyperlink. The
second thing we have is the LT-S control. The LT-S control does something
very beautiful. It divides the screen into two halves so that if
you want to read something from above, for example, and you complete
your article and you want to read something from  Underneath, you
use Control Alts and it comes back again. The
third shortcut with us is the two paths, or
grammer correction in Arabic and English. If you are writing something, for example, and the
red mark appears under the
text. Date. You press FSS. FSS along the way will
answer me. If there is anything, for example, I need to adjust it and see
what the word is.  The occasion and I
make a change for it, or I make a fourth abbreviation for it, and I
see one of the most important shortcuts in
Word, which is formatting or organizing the
text. How does it mean, for example, I have this sentence and I want to make it larger? For example, I have a quick shortcut, which is Control D, which makes the font bigger, and Control C,
which makes it smaller.  Greater than and less than. At the same time,
I have other abbreviations, which are
UPI, which is underlined. If we notice here above
UY and P-Control-A, it makes it. Mail-Control-
B makes it Bold. Of course, this is very important. So, if you
use the previous abbreviation, then this is still me,
for example, typing.  For a large word, I make a bold attack for it
without moving the mouse. Also, a small piece of information:
If I want to make the line like this,
because in reality, if I used a control unit under each sentence, I would find it
working on the whole line. Well,
if I want to work only on the words, as we see that.  I
will go to the sentence I
want and use Control FtW and I will find that it
works for me to speak, but without the commas
between them, the number six is ​​an abbreviation that we all know, which is
Copy and Best. If I want to do Copy for anything I
know, I do Control C instead of
Right Click and Copy and go to the place I am.
I want to control what is being done in best number seven, which is an
important abbreviation. Most of us know that it is the return,
but some of us do not know the redo or the opposite of the return. I mean, for example, I
will return to the text that I wrote to
God above this, I will make a control again, and he will return it to me. Well, if
I return to my mind and I want to return it again, control and
yes.  It is the opposite of Control Z Control
Y, number 8 is an abbreviation. I also find it very important
that I take the format from the text, meaning
that I want this text to be the same as the one above. Of
course, what I do using the manual method
that I know about, and I make a copy of the format
and go to the other side on my way.  It is easier
than that if I teach this part and do
Control Ft C and go to the second control. What I
find is that it takes the same breath. Thus, if I did
Control Shift In on all the content, it takes the same
as I was and I take from it the ninth shortcut copy,
which is for people who do not know.  It is formatted
well. There is something called Auto Format so that the
text is forgotten. I mean, for example, I want to
format this text. I don’t know how to put it on the internet, and I know
all about it. I want better formatting than that. I will
make the Alt-Key Control and Alt-KeyPins control for me in a
way that I see as suitable for number 10, and I also see that it is also
formatted.  One of the necessary things is the clip
board. This is the place where
anything you made a copy for is lost. If you want to look
at it and see what you are doing to the copy, you can
return to it. After that, you will go up here to the left and
click on this mark. You will find that it will answer all the
needs that you need.  You made
Copy No. 11 from it, and it is also a feature. It is her idea that
when you come to open a new rose, you still need a
specific font to work with, or you are used to working with a specific font, so you
like to click on this sign. The
place will bring you the font. You choose the
font you want, if we say, for example, Dubai
Font, for example.  Okay, so you choose the type of font
you want for font A, for example 14, and you do the
Default system. The Default system tells you that you want to work
on the first font that you will open as a new one. Oh, I
want any new font that you want to open, and it will be like this. The
number 12 is also a simple abbreviation, which is the Print
Preview.  Print Preview gives you
your file 13, which is a code for the file
you are working on. If you want to make a code, you have
Control S, of course, CIF, and there is
another abbreviation, F12. Your automatic machine will
open the file for you, open it and run it. You
can change its name to a new file number 14,
which is also the abbreviation that we are supposed to do.  We
still know that it is a control that opens as we see a
new one, and the abbreviation after it is Control, which allows you to
create an
OP for you or the files you have, Control
B of course, this creates a print for the file you
want to choose from here, and Control
W. Also keep in mind that if you click on it, it
creates a close for the file that you want.  We are working on it
completely after that. If we want to search inside
the file in which we are writing a specific word,
for example, we press Control F to open a
navigation place. I can type in, for example, Homeland and make an
automatic interplayer for any place in the
search. I have it called Homeland and the shortcut is number 19. I
forgot to say  It is also for formatting. If I
want to move my text to the right, to the left, or to the center,
Control R makes the text go to the
right. If I press it again, it makes it waste space or take up
space, as we see.
Control R means that it
makes the text remain in the center or the content is
in the center and Control R.  It leaves the
left content last but not least in Fetchr also
very delicious. It is Replace if you take a
specific content and make it Replace, which is a control. What is the
control? What does it tell you to turn on a specific word and
replace it with another word? Of course, this is very useful to us if
we are in Excel, for example, or in Word, we are looking for
words.  A lot and we want to modify it. For example, any word in which the
homeland is written, replace it with
Polg. For example, okay. There is something called Yes. The
first thing you find is Os. The first thing that exists is R. A. We
will notice that it is a turn on 13 words and do it with
Ysent or and modify it to notice and escape. We made
Control F to rotate. Thank
you very much.  Don't forget to look at the links
in the script. If you don't know much about
Word or Excel, if you're a pro at it, send these
links to other people. Surely other people are searching for them and
developing your brain on the subject of ASL and these
things. You can actually, in an hour and a
half or two, still know the shortcuts for
Excel and what they do.  Word and learn programming as well. I will
see you in a new video. May God’s peace, mercy, and blessings be upon you